Speaker 1: You want to see what happens when your
brain gets infected by maggot brain worms? Well,
I have a voicemail for you today. It's been
a while since we did one like this. We have
a voicemail number. That number is 2192. David
P, here is a caller suffering from very severe
maggot brain worms. A sad condition. I don't
think ivermectin or hydroxy will cure it.
Speaker 2: Hey, Mr. David
White, your Pacman live car.
Speaker 1: So that's Mr. David White guilt. Pacman
Lib tard. I know it was hard to hear. It sounded
like white girt, but that's what he said.
Speaker 2: I can't wait till we get a test in
California or New York or Florida. So you
can. So all the men can say that they're
all females as soon as we get attacked. Right.
Speaker 1: And then all the men will say they
are females when they get attacked so they don't
have to serve in the military. But as far as I
knew, women did serve in the military.
Speaker 2: To be able to fight because
everyone's a female. Using your logic
because you're a white guilt led card.
Speaker 1: So interestingly, a lot of
my haters say I'm not white because I'm
Jewish. This is a really interesting
thing, actually. There is disagreement
on whether Jews are white because the
right wing neo-Nazis love to say, no,
no, no, no, no. Jews are not white. But
the right wingers who don't like Jews,
because Jews generally are quite progressive.
One of the most progressive voting blocs left
to say Jews are just privileged white guilt.
Speaker 2: White people don't understand.
Oh, I can't wait. Wait. Yeah, that's
what it's going to take for leotards
like you. You guys are going
to. Oh, it's going to take
attack on the homeland for you guys to realize
that the genders are going to go into their actual
roles. Men are going to be men and women are going
to be women. It's going to take that only for you.
White guilt led cars that are ruining the world,
trying to socially engineer everyone. Oh, guys,
it's going to be all going to be next level.
Speaker 1: All right. So this guy seems very
excited about an attack on the homeland that
he believes is coming. I don't know how you
cure that. I'm not even going to weigh in. I don't
know how you cure that. We have a great bonus show
today. I won't even tell you what's on it because
it's so explosive. But I hope you'll join me. You
can sign up at join Pacman dot com and you will
instantly, instantly get access to the bonus.